and speaking of streaming the streaming
wars are escalating with Disney Plus
launching today it's the latest
streaming service competing with current
offerings like Netflix Hulu CBS all
access and Apple TV NBC Universal and
Warner media are expected to release
their own new platforms early next year
Jonathan Vigliotti reports on how all of
this could cost consumers more than
they're already paying they're calling
it the new golden age of television
switch to manual navigation more choices
than ever before
but for Roseanne Ramirez and her two
kids it poses very modern challenges I
just don't see the point in paying for
so much streaming and cable and
everything all at the same time I think
that's just too many too many networks
too many streaming shows too many just
overall the family currently has
traditional cable and watches some of
their favorite shows and movies on
Netflix and YouTube what's the max
number of streaming services that you
see yourself having at any given moment
I think it depends on I guess what's on
them how much I'm paying but I would
probably say between three and five
would be max nearly 70% of Americans
subscribe to at least one streaming
platform at a new Wall Street Journal
poll finds Americans are willing to pay
for an average of three point six
streaming services or spend forty four
dollars per month but choosing which
platforms to support can be tricky
especially as media giants like Disney
grab their a regional content back from
other services for years all of these
big entertainment companies have been
licensing a lot of their shows to
Netflix and then now what they've
realized is we need that programming on
our own platforms to survive Amol Sharma
is the Wall Street Journal's media
editor this is still Netflix is game to
lose they have a hundred and fifty eight
million customers around the world
they're way ahead of everybody but there
really is a threat from all of these new
services they they each have something
special that they bring to the table
let's say you wanted to watch
high-profile shows from each of eight
different streaming platforms programs
like Netflix who stranger things
amazon's fleabag and HBO succession
staying current on all of these programs
from all of these streaming
this won't come cheap we've added it all
up and depending on what service you
subscribe to you could be paying
anywhere from around 68 bucks to as much
as a hundred $34 Sharma says the average
cable bill runs around $90 a month and
points out that viewers who turn to
streaming will need to factor in the
costs of a Smart TV or an Internet
device and high-speed Internet plan
Sharma believes customers need to
consider how much time and money they
want to spend watching TV you're gonna
have to make some choices to keep an eye
on your budget and that means only the
shows that you absolutely want to watch
week after week and the movies that you
absolutely need to have access to and
one more thing to keep in mind streaming
companies are concerned more customers
will share their passwords to cut costs
I have absolutely no idea what they're
talking about
Amazon a coalition and this is scary
that includes Amazon Netflix HBO and
Disney is now discussing tactics to
address the issue reportedly including
periodic password resets and restricting
access based on geographical location so
Galle you're gonna have to make some
tough choices coming up I say Jonathan
somebody's looking at your account right
now thank you very much but I think if
you've got kids in the house Disney Plus
is a lot for you the original content
that you get yeah and they're gonna have
no their original programming and
they're gonna have new original content
too but there's a lot of options out
there CBS all access I think will soon
have some Nickelodeon programming that's
right could happen it can all be really
overwhelming yeah it's the most
important thing is keep watching
television
yes exactly exactly the best advice of
all